I don't understand how anyone left or
right can essentially put forward the
idea that you were going to deny
somebody a place at a university or on a
grad program for the simple reason that
they are the wrong color skin or that
they are the wrong sex to me it's
abhorrent yeah I I I feel the same way
but we're up against a bureaucracy in a
system
that is totally and fully committed to
just the opposite I mean they want to
create a racial spoil system in which
individuals are punished or rewarded
based on their ancestry I find it uh
disgusting I find it abhorrent
um and and that's what I'm fighting
against in any kind of Reform effort
there will be winners and losers and
who's losing in this regard are the
people who were very comfortable
maintaining Orthodoxy administering
their Echo chamber we're challenging
that in terms of political power we're
submitting their ideologies to a
democratic test and I think they're
squealing in in large part because
they're losing
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a terrific and
returning guest today is an activist is
the author of a new book called
America's Cultural Revolution and the
subject of the most hit pieces in the
last week that I've ever read about
anybody Christopher roofer welcome back
to trigonometry
it's good to be with you it's great to
be with you I mentioned the headpieces
people of course will will have seen our
first interview with you so they know
who you are I would say you're one of
the most effective people at dismantling
the diversity inclusion and Equity the
die industry in America
um and I suspect that is why you're
coming under attack but before we get
into that tell everybody about some of
the things you've been doing in
education in America and the results
that you've had
yeah this year my my big Focus for my
reporting my activism and other facets
of my work is uh to put pressure on and
abolish diversity equity and inclusion
departments in public universities so I
did an investigative reporting campaign
exposing these uh a kind of ideological
uh commissars in Florida and Texas
worked with Governor DeSantis worked
with legislators in Texas uh both of
those States abolished their Dei
departments and public universities they
will be totally eliminated by the end of
the summer and phased out and we also
had this incredible project the governor
of Florida Ronda Sanders appointed me as
a board member of the smallest Public
University in the state of part of this
new slate of board uh activist board
members and we were tasked with
something very simple he said turn this
university around and make it a
classical liberal arts institution and
so these are some of the big projects
that I've been working on and I think
that the reason there's been such a
furious reaction is because I'm not just
fighting in
the abstract I'm not just writing
another think piece but actually
challenging left-wing Orthodoxy and
challenging more importantly left-wing
power within Academia which is of course
their primary institution I am I'm
racking up some big wins
you are and that's that's why you're
getting a lot of the the negative
attention right now what's interesting
to me is you talk you're not talking
about a conservative education system
you're talking about a classical liberal
education what what does that look like
exactly what does that mean for people
thinking because I think you people
would rightly see you as someone on the
center right and a lot of conservatives
feel that the left is pushing the
education system too far to the left uh
and the natural reaction for them is to
demand a sort of very conservative
reaction but you're talking about
classical liberal education what does
that mean and why is that your focus
so the the mission that we've adopted
and we're trying to implement over the
next few years is to restore classical
Notions of liberal education and what
that means is you know liberal education
comes from the Latin Liber meaning three
so it's an education befitting a free
human being befitting a free society and
it's an education that is not oriented
towards partisan ideological and
political fights the kind of questions
of the day but oriented towards the
highest transcendental Goods you have
the true The Good the beautiful you have
philosophy history Aesthetics art all of
the great uh disciplines the seven Great
disciplines of the classical liberal
arts and in addition some of more
practical disciplines because it's a
public university you want kids that
attend have a chance to get a success in
the job market after graduation
but what it means in practice is that
what we've done is we've put in a new
president we've put in a new Provost
we're designing a Core Curriculum that
is going to take students through the
Greeks the Romans the Renaissance the
American founding all of the great uh
historical periods looking at literature
history of philosophy logic rhetoric and
other great disciplines and then what it
also means is rebalancing the
universities and this is something
that's happening at new college but I'm
hoping happens more broadly what you
have right now is a left-wing Echo
chamber and it's not good for
conservatives who are excluded largely
from the academic environment but it's
actually not good for liberals either
that kind of set left liberals or even
far left liberals because their ideas
are never Talent their ideas are never
tested their ideas are never
tested with this kind of friction of
debate and so what we're hoping to do is
have a wide variety of viewpoints um I
know that's shocking and offensive to
some some but we want to have a real
debate we want to have good rules of
civil civil discourse we want to have
people from all parts of the spectrum
and what that means is a rebalancing has
to occur and for some people this is
painful but uh for some people
um it's exciting it's a process of
renewal
I completely agree Chris I think it's
very very important as somebody who
still identifies with a lot of left-wing
principles I I think it's very important
why do you think that there's been so
much backlash to what you're trying to
implement in these colleges or in this
college in particular
I mean since the late 1960s the left has
uh has made the University's uh its
wholly owned subsidiary I mean this is
the base of their power they have
saturated these institutions with
left-wing ideology they've established
bureaucracies of diversity equity and
inclusion that function as activist
training departments or or
Orthodoxy enforcement agencies and so
what I'm doing is I'm saying this has to
pass muster with the Democratic test do
the people of the State of Florida
support this kind of activity in their
public universities or do they not and
the Mandate that was given to Governor
DeSantis by the voters of Florida and
his resounding re-election win indicates
that voters do not consent to this kind
of governance they do not want left-wing
ideological commissars running their
public universities and Governor
DeSantis is the kind of man who asked
the Courage the tenacity the
self-discipline and the intelligence to
actually go after it and and start
reforming these institutions and so in
any kind of Reform effort there will be
winners and losers and who's losing in
this regard are the people who were very
comfortable maintaining Orthodoxy
administering their Echo chamber we're
challenging that in terms of political
power we're submitting their ideologies
to a democratic test and I think they're
squealing in in large part because
they're losing both the intellectual
case and also the Practical political
case
what do you ask
ing in and what strategies are you using
there are a couple key strategies so
legislatively the the the the bill that
passed the Florida legislature and was
signed by the governor
um earlier this year
um does a few things that are really
important one it sets uh Hey it
abolishes Dei departments you know from
the exposes that I wrote it was very
clear that these departments were not
advancing pluralism or tolerance or
acceptance of a wide variety of
viewpoints and people but they were
actually enforcing a dog line an
Orthodoxy and they were using public
resources to push left-wing ideology
saying that the United States was a
racist country pushing BLM uh training
students had to participate in violent
protests
etc etc and so this bill eliminates
those departments just zeros amount and
says no more uh left-wing ideology
within the administrative bureaucracy
couple other reforms that are really
important the second one is that it it
restrains the Core Curriculum to say we
have to have a Core Curriculum that
teaches students the basics of getting a
liberal education of being a productive
citizen of understanding uh uh what it
means to be a human being in the United
States and a free Society so there's a
reform to the to the to the general
education requirements in Florida's
public universities and then third it
reforms the hiring process what's
happened in so many universities and I
expose this in Florida
they're putting race-based preferences
and they're putting ideological
preferences so and and which results in
this uh Department structure where many
departments are ten to one twenty to one
Thirty to one a hundred to one left to
right and so if you have a department in
a public university system that is a
hundred to one left wing to right win
you don't have free speech you don't
have debate you don't even have a
substantive intellectual uh uh
environment and so
um I think that changing some of the
hiring process restricting some of the
uh discriminatory hiring processes
giving University presidents greater
discretion can help start to rebalance
uh the the the
intellectual environment so that
students can hear from a variety of
perspectives students can test their
ideas against one another and against
their their their their professors and
faculty members and I think that is
ultimately what's going to create a
great Public University system is having
a dedication to the liberal arts having
a Core Curriculum that educates citizens
and having a a plural kind of
pluralistic intellectual environment
where students get exposed to more than
just one set of ideas
and Chris when you were talking about
the college and the curriculum I'm
thinking as a as a dad of a young boy
that is exactly the sort of place I'd
want him to be educated the classics
logic re all of these things sound
incredible but I I suppose I'm a little
bit concerned and and I'm curious to
hear your opinion about this that we've
now got ourselves into a position as
your society and ours where we
automatically evaluate a professor by
the politics if you like and I'm I'm not
saying you have done this of course but
do you think we're ever going to get to
a point where you you're going to have
colleagues in a department that don't
even particularly know each other's
politics because they are teaching Greek
history or you know ancient Latin or
something like that are we ever going to
go back to that if we were ever there
yeah I I mean there's there's two ways
of looking at that question I mean first
in some sense it would be nice if you're
running a uh you know statistics and
data science department if it wasn't you
know fully saturated with politics and
ideology you know if you're doing you
know quantum physics think about quantum
physics not about you know uh you know
how many genders there might be
um and so it in some sense I think for
certain disciplines that makes sense but
in others it doesn't make sense at all I
mean ultimately what I think is
important for people to realize is that
there's a distinction between ideology
and politics and my contention that I've
Advanced and has gotten a lot of
pushback
um but but I think is is ultimately
still true is that our universities have
been overly ideologized but
insufficiently politicized and so what
that means is that we have you know
critical theory post-modern
post-modernism gender ideology driving
intellectual life in the Departments but
we have this fiction that universities
are neutral spaces that should not be
governed by anyone and that certainly
shouldn't be intruded upon by
legislators and taxpayers and voters who
fund them Charter them and pay for them
what I'm saying is that it's time for
public universities to be governed in
the best interest of the public and to
be governed specifically by the
legislators who are elected by voters uh
to to fund oversee and administer these
institutions academics want to be free
to push their ideology at all times but
they also want to be free of democratic
oversight I hope that to reverse that I
hope that the opposite becomes true over
time
Chris what happened to the notion and as
a former teacher and everybody who
watches this show can now drink because
I mention it at least six times an
episode
but when I was a teacher I taught
theater in secondary school and I was a
primary school teacher my opinion was my
politics were completely irrelevant to
my job I left my politics at the door
and my job was to educate the students
into my subject or in Primary School in
the subjects that I taught to the very
best of my ability and quite frankly my
politics was my business and nobody
else's
well you you have a very uh very
sophisticated reserve and
self-discipline uh I think that's what
maybe so describes it but look I had the
same experience in my K-12 education
even in some of my college education
um you know you have a lot of professors
who you don't even know their politics
you couldn't you couldn't guess you
might be surprised if you heard their
personal politics their partisan
politics
um I think that is generally good I mean
especially in K-12 you should absolutely
check your politics at the door
um in University and environment look if
you're a university professor and you're
studying some or you're rather teaching
something that is intertwined with
politics your politics might come out
but the best professors that I've had at
that at the higher education level were
professors who also sought to create a
balance within the course syllabus for
example to say we're going to pair Adam
Smith with Karl Marx we're going to pair
um you know uh kind of the the
Federalists and the Anti-Federalists
we're going to pair uh you know the you
know Ibraham Kennedy with John McWhorter
if you want to have them work kind of
contemporary and and a more immediate
question and so I I think that that is
the ideal
um but I think that we should not
mistake that
um kind of micro level
um uh concealing of politics in a sense
you're concealing it because it's not
exactly relevant just like you should
conceal uh you know your sex life uh
from your from your students I mean this
is kind of Common Sense
but we should not mistake that for
um uh concealing the fact that public
universities are political entities
they're created by politicians and and
so I think that we have this um two
levels where this question must be asked
and there are two different answers
and I suppose the question is uh about
trying to get to a position because look
when I think about my University
education I was not I studied economics
and politics I was not taught
to believe Karl Marx I was taught about
Karl Marx and I was taught about Adam
Smith and the ideas of the Anita and all
these other philosophers I was taught
about their ideas instead of being
indoctrinated with their ideas right
um I suppose that's what we're trying to
get with you is are we ever going to get
to that point or is it just now going to
be about uh you know everyone being
obsessed with their View and imposing it
on students forever now it sounds like
you're making progress on that front
yeah that that we absolutely are making
progress and and so I have a bit more of
a
a subtle take on the question of
indoctrination a lot of conservatives
say universities are indoctrinating kids
to be you know blue-haired gender
Communists
um that's kind of a meme that you see
everywhere and and okay I mean I could
understand why why at first glance you
might think that but I don't think
that's exactly how it works I don't
think that most professors
um are are are are you kind of
consciously in a cult-like manner
indoctrinating their students pushing
their ideology uh you know you know
converting them to the to the to the
cause in that kind of recruiting sense I
actually think it's something more
subtle and more Insidious I think that
it's just that they're not exposing
students to any alternative sets of
ideas and so there was a piece from the
guardian
a critical piece of me that came out
yesterday in the guardian that that
illustrates exactly what's happening
this is a college-educated writer Moira
done again
um who made the media men list which was
kind of a horrific thing that that that
that that uh you know start her
reputation but then she's a you know
visiting teacher at Stanford in the
gender studies Department this is
someone who is teaching at an elite
University in some capacity someone who
has a prestigious spot as a columnist at
the guardian
um and then she says you know I wouldn't
go that far
[Laughter]
mateous these days yeah okay once
prestigious uh maybe but uh you know but
she says in this piece she says rufa
wants to turn the curriculum at new
College of Florida and base it on logos
uh nobody knows what the word logos
means it means word and Greek how are
you going to make a curriculum based on
word and so
what does this person missing this
person is missing that logos was the
heart of Greek philosophy and then also
the heart of the the kind of Christian
biblical tradition you know in in at the
in the beginning was the word was the
logos
um and of course you know Herodotus
Aristotle
um all of the Greek philosophers
commented on logos and then there's been
two thousand years of commentary on
logosis rationality discourse language
word
um uh uh logic I mean the the very uh
description of how the the the the order
of the cosmos is constructed is all
embedded in that word logos
um she doesn't have any idea can't even
recognize that it's a philosophical word
can't even recognize that it's a
religious word can't even recognize that
it's one of the most important words in
the past 2000 years in the history of
the West and so this person is
indoctrinated as a kind of gender
cultist
not merely because someone was forcing
it into her mind although it's possible
that also happen but because she has
been deprived of any education in the
classical liberal arts to the point
where she can't even recognize the key
terms of the past two Millennia and so
um that's what we're trying to do where
I think you know I look back at my own
education
I feel like I was robbed of an education
I was deprived of the the great
traditions of of the West not having
been exposed to some of these classical
ideas classical Concepts and classical
uh uh pedagogies until much later in
life
that's such an interesting point man and
one of the things I also wanted to ask
you about because uh you're very funny
with the hip pieces that you get on
Twitter I enjoy uh back and forth with
you and one of the things I found is
both your supporters and your critics
are agreed on what you're doing and and
so when I read the hit pieces on you
quite often I'm like going oh this
sounds like he's doing good things
because a lot of them focus on the fact
that you are dismantling the diversity
industry and from my perspective that is
an unquestioned good because I just see
it as a new form of racism that's been
allowed to to be perpetuated on the
British and American institutions for
far too long but for people who are
perhaps you know less initiated in the
culture war in all of this what what is
the difference between
you know in America you guys always
celebrate oh this person is the first
Italian-American to do this or this
person is the first African-American to
do that and that was never really a
thing that was discriminatory it was a
celebratory way of doing things but
we've kind of got way past that towards
affirmative action which openly
discriminated against certain people and
stuff like that so why is getting rid of
the diversity hierarchy a good thing
well in public universities it's an
especially crucial question so
um look I think most Americans if not
the you know the vast majority of
Americans uh want people from all
backgrounds to succeed that's part of
our national Mythos that this is a place
where you can come with nothing and you
can succeed
um you know with you know debate about
immigration and and Etc set aside for
their time being that's a core part of
the American story
um and and so but when you look at
universities you have to ask the
question what is the university for what
is the purpose I think that the
university is to pursue truth
um to to pursue uh to to rather to
produce knowledge uh and to serve as a
community of Scholars from a variety of
viewpoints that together through the
process of reasoning and debate uh and
and and constructive criticism Can Can
it can reveal or can touch or can arrive
at those great transcendentals the true
the good and the Beautiful
um so you have you know of course uh
philosophy ethics and Aesthetics or art
um those are the kind of three uh
channels that we can create
um you know truth and beauty and so
Dei bureaucracies in practice are are
antithetical to those Pursuits Dei
bureaucracies enforce Orthodoxy you know
I've exposed public universities that
are literally telling people these are
words that you can use these are words
that you can't use you shouldn't say men
and women you should say people and
people kind you know you shouldn't say
black and white you should say you know
something else I mean it's like down to
the minute management of language by
bureaucracy
and so I think that it stifles open
discourse it stifles uh free debate uh
it stifles even the basic process of
learning it also then serves as a racial
spoils system they have hiring and
admissions based on your on your
ancestry rather than your academic
capability they're rewarding people and
punishing People based on what their
parents uh you know what their who their
parents are uh where where their
ancestors came from and I think that is
really deeply destructive and especially
undermines the concept of meritocracy
and so in the American context you know
of course you know what Jefferson
thought of as having a a natural
aristocracy of talent and of course
wasn't fully implemented during his
lifetime obviously but we've moved uh
toward that toward that goal more and
more and I think that the Dei
bureaucracy undermines uh that as well
and then as a third component what the
Dei bureaucracy does
um is it manages the university and
transforms it away from the pursuit of
the the transcendentals and toward the
pursuit of the current day political
activism I mean it's training programs
it's student programs it's faculty
programs they want to turn universities
away from the pursuit of knowledge and
towards the pursuit of ideology and the
pursuit of partisan activism that
betrays the fundamental mission of the
universities and I think it portrays
really the scam that the Dei bureaucracy
is it operates in these very nice
buzzwords but in practice I think
destroys the very heart of liberal
education
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who can executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
bull deodorant crumb reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20 up
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life
when it comes to ticking boxes when it
comes to diversity look as a former
teacher I saw plenty of kids who were
really talented really smart had the
ability to go to college University but
the reality is weren't going to go there
because the schools that they went to
were to put it mildly absolutely
Dreadful in which no learning took place
because bad behavior under funding etc
etc is there not something to be said
for having quotas for these types of
kids who have got a huge amount of
ability but because the education system
has to put it bluntly failed them the
universities can step in and maybe help
to actually propel them forward in their
careers
yeah I think there are two um methods
for attracting you know kids that are
having those kind of difficulties into
the university environment that also are
consonant with the principle of
colorblind equality treating people
equally and not giving you know favor or
punishment based on Ancestry you can do
a couple things one is uh there's a
great system in Texas that says
if you're in the top 10 of your high
school graduating class and any High
School in Texas you're automatically
admitted into the University of Texas
system and so what that does is there
are you know of course many affluent
Public Schools uh where much more than
the top 10 percent are going to college
they're qualified they're they're
habituated to it they're encouraged by
their parents but for those struggling
high schools everyone knows if you get
that top 10 you're in you can get to
College that's a way that I think in a
sense disproportionately benefits those
who are at the lower end of the
socioeconomic class by virtue of proxy
and including many minority students but
it does it in a neutral colorblind
manner that I think targets the the
right thing is saying if you're a top
performer at your at any one of our
Public Schools
um you you deserve a spot you deserve a
chance
um the other method that you can do and
I think that it that it's a method that
that is that is commonplace and
certainly happens in the State of
Florida is that you can reward
scholarships or or tuition reductions
based on socioeconomic status so if
you're coming from a family uh you know
like my family I had two lawyers as
parents uh you know I had to go for
those Merit Scholarships I was not
qualifying for those uh Financial need
scholarships that's fine uh but if
you're coming from someone who's say a
great student but comes from a
background where you have maybe one
parent or two parents you know working
minimum wage let's say
um I think that it's right and just and
good to give those folks a break if not
a a full break on tuition for public
universities for which they're qualified
but the third thing that's really
important is that
this is really what the SATs were
designed to do standardized tests in the
mid-century period the ivy league
universities were kind of an old boys
club uh where your dad went to Harvard
you went to Harvard your son went to
Harvard and so what they did is they
created these sat tests so that kids
from all over the United States and
inner cities and small towns and rural
areas could compete in a very uh
objective in a in a kind of quantitative
sense against all of their other peers
and what this allowed was for those
great Ivy League schools at the time and
those public universities as well to
find those uh those kids who were
immense talents who had the brains who
had the intelligence who had the the you
know the capacity to do well
um but weren't connected uh socially or
or administratively with the
universities this gave them an
opportunity to prove themselves and so
these are three solutions that I think
solved the problem where left and right
mostly agree but they do it in a manner
that doesn't create result sentiment
hostility frustration and isn't also a
violation of our constitution
look I completely agree I don't
understand how anyone left or right can
essentially put forward the idea that
you are going to deny somebody a place
at a university or on a grad program for
the simple reason that they are the
wrong color skin or that they are the
wrong sex to me it's abhorrent
yeah I I I feel the same way and
sometimes I wonder it's a very very
simple uh conclusion it's a very simple
position it happens to be very popular
with large majorities of the public but
we're up against a bureaucracy in a
system that is
you totally and fully committed to just
the opposite I mean they want to create
a racial spoil system in which
individuals are punished or rewarded
based on their ancestry I find it uh
disgusting I find it abhorrent
um and and that's what I'm fighting
against it yeah and one of the things I
was going to ask you Chris is you have
been very effective I would say
uncommonly so among the people who are
attempting to challenge the very things
that we've just been talking about so
what do you think it is that you have
been doing that other people have
perhaps not been doing because I think
we all would would agree that there is
kind of now a quite a large ecosystem of
people who are concerned about the same
things that you and I are concerned
about uh an ecosystem of people who
discuss them who do podcasts about them
who interview authors who've got books
about them who write books about them
but there's a lot of talking and you're
someone who's actually converted that
into real action and Real Results what
do you think we can learn from from the
things you've been working on
well I I mean first off I I sometimes
joke that you know politics is not a
podcast you you can't win in politics on
a podcast but that's that's somewhat
tongue-in-cheek because uh the the
intellectual uh ecosystem of podcasts
journals you know social media accounts
um you know video video channels is
really really important because programs
like yours and others are are how people
start to get into the debate they start
to be thinking about these issues they
they give a platform for uh the the
great uh journalists and and writers and
intellectuals who are uh working in this
in this domain but I think it's
necessary but not sufficient and and
what is what is required to make it both
necessary and sufficient is to actually
do politics and I find it you know so
astonishing I get critics even from the
right that are saying you know
um we think critical race theory is
horrible
um we think Dei is antithetical to the
Constitution but we're really concerned
that rufo is getting rid of them within
public institutions it's like
what are you people for I mean what what
how do you go from that specific
conclusion sorry to interrupt I just a
steel man that argument and I have seen
that argument made please their argument
I think is they're uncomfortable with
using the power of government to do
those things that is their concern
totally but but that is like the most
absurd concern possible because they're
uncomfortable with using the power of
the government to regulate the
government these are government schools
these are government institutions and so
the only per the only people who can't
regulate them are the are government you
know agents essentially and so what my
argument is is if you say that
legislators
channeling the the the sentiments and
desires of their voters are not allowed
to regulate public institutions what
you're saying is that the supreme power
in our country is not the people it's
not the legislators who represent them
but the permanent bureaucracies and the
permanent bureaucrats that administer
our institutions and so it is
fundamentally an anti-democratic
argument that they're making they're
saying the people have no right to
regulate their government
um that is completely backwards to to
the to the to the vision of the American
founding where the people people were
the ultimate Arbiter and the government
only secured only existed to secure the
rights of the people
um now now we're getting into a kind of
tyrannical a model
and I think it fails on those grounds
no I agree with you and that makes a lot
of sense actually particularly when you
travel around America and you realize
how different different states are in
people's attitudes it seems strange to
me that you would want to that it's even
possible that you would have the same
values and the same attitudes everywhere
because it's just so different and so
the different states do traveling around
America has made me much more pro-states
rights just as an outside Observer I
have to say
yeah I think that's right and I mean and
I think this is ultimately good right I
think some values are better than others
obviously
um you know I I I I I support
legislation in some states and and and
do not support the legislation that gets
through in other states but what I think
I recognize and I hope most Americans
recognize is that
um we want to have a pluralistic system
I mean what is more boring what is more
humorless what is more stifling than an
entire nation a 330 plus million people
where everyone thinks the same everyone
has the same values everyone has to do
the same programs all universities look
identical to one another that's the
that's the homogeneous world that we're
drifting towards
um and and I think that what that does
is it it deadens the soul uh and I think
the people who lead those kind of
bureaucracies are some of the worst
people in our society frankly um I'll
I'll say that because they want to
um destroy uh uh the great traditions of
Western civilization and they want to
replace it uh with with with a a
desiccated
um and discriminatory system of Dei
bureaucracies
um that that simply circulate whatever
is the fashionable Orthodoxy of the day
Chris isn't your challenge going to be
as well when you're when you're talking
about recruitment there are certain
professions
for instance becoming a teacher which is
naturally going to appeal more to
Liberal people more to left-wing people
than it is going to appeal to right-wing
people I mean that's just the reality of
life isn't it same if you're a college
professor who is a specialist in the
liberal arts chances are you're going to
be pretty liberal
I think that that is
um the
I think that that is the reality in very
recent times but has not been the
reality over the course of a longer
stretch of history and so I hear this
all the time you know well artists are
always left-win but if you look at the
18th century in the 19th century uh
there were many right-wing artists you
could actually make the case that that
uh that that that uh the the kind of
great Arts were were embodying the
spirit of the right uh the spirit of
their aristocracy the spirit of
hierarchy even
um and so I don't think that it's
inevitable um although I would certainly
admit that it's pervasive and I think
that you know from a practical
perspective if you say that the the the
the kind of ratio of of uh you know left
to right and colleges campuses among the
academics and professors is is 10 20 30
50 100 to 1 depending on the discipline
you know we have to start acknowledging
that that's the reality and one of my
personal goals
through legislation uh through kind of
governance in many different uh
conservative states red States
I want to uh see in the next 10 years
a thousand professors that are aligned
with the classical liberal arts hired in
state universities around the country
and these professors will be because
it's classical in a sense it's
conservative you're trying to conserve
the classical Notions of of of of these
ideas of these concepts of these
histories and so in a sense what I'm
hoping to do is get at least a thousand
academics that are that are broadly and
philosophically aligned uh with with so
many people who feel unrepresented in
the institution so feel like their ideas
don't have a home in Academia I think a
thousand people creates a strong enough
counterbalance
um a strong enough cohort a strong
enough Network that then you can start
taking over departments you could start
reforming entire universities you could
start launching new academic journals
you could start creating another
parallel realm of academic discourse
that provides protection that provides
patronage that provides publication
opportunities for people who dissent
from the left-wing Orthodoxy that's
something that I'm excited about and I'm
going to be working for in the future
would it not be an idea just to say as
well that when a professor enters a
classroom particularly undergrad
they are not allowed to present a
political argument and say this is the
way that you should think that it is
their Duty as an as an educator to go in
and present these arguments neutrally
would that not also be a way of doing it
there is an argument for that and so um
but I think that there's a better
solution to that I I think that the
better solution is to hire people in the
first place that are already predisposed
to that kind of temperament and that
kind of pedagogy in the classroom and so
I think that it fundamentally this is a
hiring problem a recruiting problem
um and a faculty problem in that sense
um but however
um
some states are now experimenting with
restricting
certain pedagogies in the classroom I
personally have expressed reservation
about this I've done it at the debate
that I did at Stanford and I said look I
think that um this is probably not the
best place for conservatives to fight my
own model legislation that I've put
together with Manhattan Institute
provides a kind of exemption for
classroom instruction focuses more on
the bureaucracy and hiring and and
colorblind policies however the states
such as Florida that are that are
experimenting with that approach
um will be challenging the courts but my
view is that they'll Prevail in the
courts because we have a supreme court
Precedent symbios versus Garcetti that
says that public employees including
Public University employees presumably
are ultimately uh uh they have a job and
in their official duties they do not
have unlimited First Amendment rights so
you can't go into a kindergarten in
classroom and say
um you know all of you must be
Communists your parents are are evil and
you know I declare you all you know cat
gender uh well you can't you can get
fired for that because you don't have
unlimited First Amendment rights you
have a job that you're doing you're
hired to do specific tasks
the question is does it apply to uh
higher education academics in a college
classroom
um again even my own reservations about
the policy I I think that it does I
think ultimately uh College professors
are in public universities are public
employees and they're subject to
reasonable oversight and they're subject
to to kind of the reasonable uh uh
preferences of legislators and
administration
I know you I know I guess I know what
your answer is going to be to this but
there's a lot of people that we speak to
who are in higher education or have been
higher in higher education who say
that it's completely compromised and
actually the most effective strategy now
is to build the uh our own institutions
as it were what do you say to that
argument
I I I think that it is uh Noble in
spirit but deficient in its practical uh
uh implementation because the fact is is
that founding in the university is
extremely expensive and it's also very
onerous as far as accreditation and
launch and Recruitment and Facilities
um and and we cannot do that at the
scale to compete with the existing
institutions look I support initiatives
like University of Austin
the new University that's uh uh that
that they're launching is kind of like
IDW University in a sense uh you know
heterodox University
um I think that that's great but the
fact of the matter is that we have 3 000
other universities and if your argument
is that most of them are compromised oh
you have to do something about it and
and while it's very hard to influence
say a private institution in the IB
leagues
um although there are ways we can talk
about that where what we know we can
absolutely influence in a profound way
are public universities because
ultimately if you have control of the
legislature and the governor's mansion
you can do in a sense whatever you want
whatever you can get passed through the
legislative process and so I think that
that is a much more immediate and much
more fruitful and a much more scalable
method and so
um you put in conservative oriented
research centers you do University
takeovers uh uh uh as small universities
um you reform The Faculty hiring process
to get more power to trustees and and
University presidents to create a little
bit more balance on the faculty and then
you also make sure that you're you're
restricting eliminating Republican
programs that don't serve the public
good
um that that's what I think is is the
best path
um although it is of course certain
certainly complementary rather than
contradictory or or antithetical to
um the idea of also creating new
institutions and I imagine you're
hopeful that the marketplace sorts the
weed from the chaff in other words 5 10
15 years from now where there's enough
colleges that have that classical
liberal arts education available uh that
people vote with their feet and and then
the proof of that pudding gets shown I'm
curious though coming back to the point
about uh lessons for other things uh
what do you think are the lessons from
what you've been doing into other things
because you you would know full well
that this capture that we're talking
about with the education system also
applies to things like the media do you
think given that those things are not
owned and run by the government do you
think that that is an area where it is
about building your own institution or
do you think that in other areas it has
to be about something like what you're
doing with education yeah a great great
question and very much the former I I
think that the media is
um thankfully with very limited
exceptions for you know NPR and PBS and
and Federal grant making the media in
the United States is a is a kind of
private Enterprise
um the media is a kind of an open system
and so I'm I'm very much uh I think that
we want to have
um uh you know
print media broadcast Media Radio social
media conservatives just need to build
they need to compete they need to create
great material and I think that they
need to create also businesses and I
think that the rest mostly solves itself
the only glaring exception where I think
it's appropriate for Public Policy
um is uh is under conditions of private
Monopoly
um some government uh intervention is is
Justified even under a Libertarian
reading and so
um I think that there is some role
although it has to be delicate on uh
social media center censorship for
example
particularly with those kind of
vertically integrated and and uh kind of
Monopoly uh monopoly-like firms
um and so I I'd like to see
um
some new ideas in that direction but but
broadly speaking
um I think the media is actually I mean
look the success of your show uh the
success of some of my uh my journalistic
work
um the the limitation is not you know
the system the limitation is not that
you know uh kind of left far left people
have taken over the the you know NBC
News uh room the limitation is really
that we have to to compete and create
great work
um and I think that the role of policy
is quite Limited
Chris and let's focus on the Ivy Leagues
the the harvards you know the Columbians
Etc these are private institutions
correct me if I'm wrong because I'm I'm
not particularly okay okay so what do we
do with a private Institution
because that's not governmental so what
do we do with them
well this is actually a fun question and
I'm glad you asked because I've been
working with some other Scholars and
policy analysts on exactly this question
and there's a couple things we can do I
mean uh you know a private universities
are subsidized to the deals by the
federal government through student loans
and student loan guarantees and so I
think that you could reform student
loans and make universities liable in
part for student loan defaults so if a
student racks up 25 you know 250 000 in
student loans getting a gender studies
degree from you know private university
a uh and then can't pay it back well why
isn't the university on the hook to
repay that say half of that loan so
create some Financial incentives for
them to be
um uh more more competitive and more
judicious in how they they run their
their programs
second what you can do and what I'm
recommending uh the next president of
the United States to do uh you know if
it's a republican
um is is to launch a Department of
Justice and Department of Education
investigation into all of the ivy league
universities uh to investigate them for
uh illegal and unconstitutional racial
discrimination in hiring and Admissions
and so what we would do is essentially
take what what the the lawyers did with
the Harvard lawsuit which established
that that Harvard's admissions policies
was unconstitutional
um
we're unconstitutional and then expanded
to all of the prestige universities
using the power of federal investigation
um to to procure documents to put you
know a few hundred lawyers on the case
uh and and in a sense to to to embarrass
to expose to punish and then to take
corrective legal action against
universities who are violating the
Constitution I think that would make
waves I think that would make huge
changes in behavior and I also think
that Federal uh Federal funding uh for
these universities they get billions of
dollars private universities get
billions of dollars in in Grants and in
programmatic funding and other kind of
uh federal financial schemes
why don't we tie that funding to
principles of open speech and debate
principles of Civic discourse principles
of non-discrimination
um and and in a sense say
um if you don't fulfill the basic
mission of the University being a home
for open discourse having a standard of
civil debate you no longer qualify for
federal funds uh the this is how it
works and almost every other domain of
life it's you do not follow the basic
rules you do not qualify for special
benefits and so I think there's a lot
that can be done to to tame these
private universities and one thing I've
learned in particular fighting in
Academia
academics are not very you know they're
not economically productive right
they're they're not uh you know creating
uh you know iPhones or whatever
um what they have what they trade on is
prestige
um and that's really their fault they
always put their full the you know the
the famous Jacob yoroski professor of
whatever at Yale University uh the the
famous line from Jason Stanley and so
what I've learned by by kind of you
laugh at that it's kind of funny but but
actually it signal signals a great
vulnerability if you can um Can attack
The Prestige and attack the reputation
uh and and and and and and undermine the
The Prestige reputation of individual
academics but academic institutions as a
whole
um that is a very powerful method for
getting change
and Chris one of the things we wanted to
talk with you about as well is as I
think you can tell we're fully on board
with the idea of dismantling the
diversity bureaucracy uh classic liberal
arts education and I certainly see that
you know and you talk about this in your
book America's cultural revolution the
way that the far left has infiltrated so
many institutions and essentially seized
control of the means of intellectual
production or in all sorts of areas
um are you concerned though for example
we see that we saw the case in Florida
where I think in one County Francis and
I were looking at this article earlier
they've banned the teaching of
Shakespeare in schools because it's got
sexually explicit content and you can
kind of see what's happened there where
maybe people have felt that you know
rightly we talked to Carol Markowitz
when we were in Florida about about some
of the things that kids are being told
and you're going no no children should
not be taught this very sexually
explicit content but it it feels like
there is at least a very real risk of a
over correction overreaction a an
excessive backlash is that something
that you see happening and are you
concerned about that at all well that's
interesting I I I I don't know the
specifics of that story uh of
Shakespeare
um but but I would venture a guess you
know speculating
um uh and I would say that this is the
the pattern in many other cases that
sound like this you know you see the
headlines School bands you know
Shakespeare
you dig in a couple things might be
happening it might be I don't know in
this specific case one it might be a
single parent says hey I'm going to flag
this book and it has to go through a
process of review and then of course
it's Shakespeare it'll get reviewed and
it'll get put back in the shelf or the
curriculum or whatever is the case but
there's a second thing that is very um
commonly occurring and and it's very
sneaky and they almost never put it in
the news article because a lot of the
news articles are not news they're
they're propaganda but what's a
phenomenon sorry to interrupt Chris this
was uh just this was a New York Post by
the way just for clarity okay okay well
I I would be curious to I would be
curious to read it but but perhaps this
is what's happening there's something
called a kind of technique called
malicious compliance and I've seen this
over and over in Florida where
um kind of left-wing ideological
teachers Librarians citizens what have
you will say oh what can we do to
embarrass uh you know the governor what
can we do to to put pressure we're gonna
flag Shakespeare for a a you know a racy
a sex scene or whatever
um and then we can feed it to the media
the media will say that that that that
you know Shakespeare has been banned but
really what this is is a a librarian
um uh kind of or or another official
violating the spirit of the law
violating actually in most cases the
plain reading of the law
distorting the reading uh putting
something on a list in a kind of
manipulative and false way in order to
generate negative headlines and so I
would suspect that what you'll see is
that Chaser will be back in the library
immediately I of course would uh support
uh the complete works of Shakespeare in
the library and I think what what
parents are really uh trying to to to to
to stop is is against pornography and
sexually explicit materials you know
there's books that are teaching you know
depicting uh you know acts of pedophilia
books that are teaching children how to
how to use gay sex apps
um that's the kind of thing that is in
classrooms uh that shouldn't be in
classrooms and so I I don't think that
any conservative that I know or really
any conservatives in any meaningful
sense wants to restrict Shakespeare
um I I would suspect something else is
going on
that's it yeah that sounds perfectly
incredible Chris the one thing that I
find quite interesting and again as a
former educator is and maybe look I'm
reading a left-wing liberal paper and
it's a misrepresentation I was reading
about uh how sex education has been
banned in Florida now I'm as a former
educator I'm not particularly
comfortable with it and I'll explain to
you why because particularly with young
children sex education is not teaching
them to be sexual it's actually teaching
them to protect themselves from abuse
and children who grow up in households
that are sexually abusive are not taught
about this for very obvious reasons and
I've seen in my own experience where
cases of abuse have been missed because
a child is not able to vocalize what is
happening to them because they're not
sexual people for because they're
children
sure well I think that it's important to
then review the the text of the law
let's say in Florida where I'm most
familiar with it
um the text of the law says there there
shall be no instruction on gender
identity and sexual orientation in first
in K through three and now in K through
12.
and so and then it also has a carve out
for State mandated sex education should
be can it must be you know permitted
included in the classroom and so uh any
kind of uh uh training or prevention or
discussion about potential sexual abuse
is not about gender identity or sexual
orientation it's part of the the
existing you know K-12 sex education
curriculum there's a clear need for that
uh would not be restricted and so I
think that that is a very a good way to
look at it there are certain things that
like you know sex Abuse Prevention
education
um or reporting education that I think
are absolutely should be included that's
still in the curriculum in Florida
um but teaching kids that they might be
uh pansexual teaching children that they
might be uh you know how to use gay sex
apps I think that that is uh you know
something that maybe Beth left uh I mean
actually maybe best uh you know not in
the case of dual system at all but but
certainly if parents want to teach their
kids you know all the new genders
um you know that's their right but they
don't have uh they don't have an
entitlement to push these ideas in the
public school system come on little
Johnny let me show you how to use
grinder for kids that is a fun time with
that as as no one has experienced uh
Chris we're about to head over to locals
where we ask you questions from our
audience that they've already submitted
before we do as you know we always wrap
up this part of the interview by asking
you uh what is the one thing that we're
not talking about as a society that you
think we should be
you know I I think that it's something
that we've been touching upon a bit in
this conversation it's that
um you know we need to talk about how
democracy functions and and I think that
the left has made their slogan you know
this is what democracy looks like
democracy dies in darkness uh some other
you know there's some other kind of Rift
on this uh you know Trump is a threat to
democracy I mean all of these democracy
democracy democracy I think
conservatives though are missing uh are
missing something on on the word
democracy and also on the word justice
the left is this Justice that Justice
you know XYZ Justice
the conservatives have a Temptation and
even kind of Center center right
liberals let's say have a temptation to
say oh the left is demagoguing on
Democracy the left is demagogy on
Justice you know uh uh uh those are
those are left-wing words
I think that that's totally a missed
opportunity and in fact we need to have
a competing vision of democracy and a
competing vision of Justice
um that I think would resonate with
large majorities of the public and we've
really seeded those words seeded those
Concepts to our opponents and uh and I
think that this uh conversation about
education reform University reform
it speaks to this issue it's that
um you're in a democracy in a republic
but let's say in a democracy for kind of
shorthand
um uh the voters the people through
their legislators get to decide how
their institutions are governed and
towards which values their institutions
Aspire we've lost that in our country
maybe in your country as well we've lost
the sense that the people determine the
ends that the people determine how
institutions function that the people
determine what institutions are
transmitting from one generation to the
next
we've seeded that we've we've we've
we've closed our eyes to how our
democracy functions and I think that is
a really dangerous future if we continue
and so one of my goals against the left
and against even the right my Critics on
the right
is to unapologetically be a champion of
democratic governance of our
institutions and I think that that's a
conversation that needs to be had
perfect well if you're listening and
watching this we're going to continue
the conversation on locals head on over
there and we'll answer some of your
questions
point that pushed you so far that you
stopped caring when someone weaponized
empathy against you
foreign